alors seulement je veux dire tout à fait
clairement que je trouve qu'être attaché
à son identité
très attachée à son histoire attaché à
ses valeurs c'est dur les valeurs falala
à la française qui est beau mais qu'on
va presser qui sont les racines très
court latine qui sont le christianisme
judéo christianisme et qui sont menées
sur les lumières
il n'y a absolument rien de fascisant et
de totalitaire à être à être attaché à
ses racines
et cela même d'ailleurs qui accuse les
conceptions justement identitaires sont
ceux là mêmes qui veulent à tout prix
défendre défendre le droit à l'identité
des communautés c'est une question tout
à fait en pleine contradiction et donc
donc je ne peux pas effectivement
accepté cette attaque frontale contre
manuel valls paraît il me semble que
face à sète
cette petite critique ce jeu ce gentil
dessins de charlie hebdo contre plenel
j'ai l'impression que j'ai de vie plenel
a perdu son sang froid